[Music]
are you ready for the uk
transition number two key dates and
stages
[Music]
my name is jane rose and i'm head of
international trade at the essex
chambers of commerce
this is the second of four bite size
videos about the uk transition
which have been commissioned by rochford
district council to help businesses
prepare for the changes to trading with
the eu
contact and website details are listed
in the video description
in this video i'm going to tell you
about the three stages that the
government have put in place
to give you more time to make the
changes you need ahead of the uk
transition
from the 1st of january 2021 all goods
leaving and arriving at the uk border
will need export and import declarations
this may be new to you so let me explain
a form called a c88 or sad
a single administrative document is used
to make the declaration to customs
this is then lodged with the uk customs
computer
which is called chief chief currently
logs all movement of goods
in and out of the uk outside of the eu
and from january the 1st that will
include all trade to and from the eu as
well
completing the declaration properly
requires a lot of information and
specialist knowledge
whether it's done by you or a third
party
you'll need to find out if your goods
need a licence or special certificates
for items such as animals or animal
products
plants and plant products you'll also
need to check
to see if your goods are listed as
controlled and there'll be extra checks
at the border for certain goods
if you're importing standard goods from
the eu which is everything from clothes
to electronics
you may be able to delay the import
declaration and duties for six months
but do consider the implications in
doing this as it will have to be done
eventually
now on to the second stage from the
first of april 2021
all products of animal origin such as
meat pet food honey
milk or egg products and all regulated
plants and plant products
will need to have import
pre-notifications submitted
and the relevant health certificate and
lastly
the third and final stage from the 1st
of july 2021
you'll need to meet full customs
requirements for all imports and exports
this means providing full important
safety and security
there'll be an increase in physical
checks and all import duties and vat
will need to be paid
this is a really big change for those of
you that have only been trading with the
eu up until now
i understand that it's a lot to take in
but i hope this has given you an idea of
what you need to be doing to prepare
please do contact us at the essex
chambers of commerce if you need
training or advice
on where to start and don't forget there
are web links and references listed in
the video description thank you so much
for listening